[Music]
chuck got another explainer for you all
right this one is is fun and obscure
okay all right that's some of the best
kind are those so if you're standing
on one side of a hill okay and you've
got to get to the other side of the hill
you you're going to climb over the top
of the hill and come down the other side
yeah or i mean that's why i had children
they're going to pull me up over the
hill let them call you let them do the
work ladies
i'm gonna sit right here in this little
cart y'all get moving
so another way to do it is to bore a
hole
through the mountain through the hill
and come out the other side so true by
doing so you've made a tunnel correct
okay so you've you've you've
you've made it easier
to get from one side of the hill to the
other because you don't have to go up
and then come back down uh as a person
who lives in jersey i appreciate that
kind of there's a tunneling the
tunneling from
out of manhattan that's correct
correct okay so
um here's something
interesting in quantum physics
we can think of the hill
as a
as an energy barrier to you
okay okay that makes sense all right so
you need energy to ascend the hill
otherwise you'll just stay where you are
so now we check how much energy do you
have oh i can get halfway up the hill
but not any further three quarters of
the way
but not any further okay
so in quantum physics if there's a hill
we call them potential barriers because
all right
they're actual barriers but they're
called potential barriers they so there
it is you have a particle on one side of
that barrier and you give the particle
energy that can't make it i can't make
it okay this heel is too much
why you gotta
let's just stay here why don't we just
live here now
you wiping the sweat off your brown like
electron like electron sweat
you have no idea
how hot that nucleus
[Laughter]
so
so
what i have so
the particle however
is not only a particle it's also a wave
okay
and when you're wave this one called a
wave function and a wave function is the
probability of finding it anywhere
in a volume
spanned by that wave function
okay so you're more likely to find it
where the wave peaks and where the wave
drops off you're less and less likely to
find it there and there's a point where
don't ever wait around because it won't
show up for trillions of years all right
so
but there's an actual likelihood it can
show up anywhere in the wave function
even in the low probability places all
right so that wave doesn't know about
and doesn't care about the mountain
okay
so you can ask does some of that wave
show up on the other side of the
mountain
if it does
then there is a probability
that the particle that's stuck on one
side
will just simply appear on the other
side of the mountain
having never had to ascend it in the
first place
because it didn't have enough energy to
do it
but because it exists as a wave function
there will always be a probability that
it can show up where it was not invited
oh
that's called quantum mechanical
tunneling quantum wedding crashing
that's it
we built this wall
right did you see that potential barrier
did you see that wall does the potential
barriers mean anything to you
[Laughter]
this would be good for trump but
they built the wall
to keep you out
but they're still tunneling in
they must be quantum mechanical entities
this is the thing
why aren't these
from norway
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
why can't we get the ones from norway
they wouldn't have to tunnel
okay
so that's just quantum tunneling so
here's so i'll show you how that
manifests very interesting little
history here and then we'll call it
quits because this is just an explainer
uh in the early days 100 some years ago
we didn't know where you may where you
got all the elements in the universe
okay okay i i by the way i remembered
asking my high school chemistry teacher
where do the elements come from oh
they're in the earth and i would later
learn no we made these suckers in stars
dude all right won't you look up every
now and then that is so funny okay uh so
it's not his fault he's a chemistry
teacher he he thinks and we know how
stupid they are
come on
let's be honest he's a chemistry teacher
he's no physicist come on what do you
want jack
so
so
uh so in the early days the question was
where do we get these elements from
you could build them from smaller
elements
all right if you merge them
so they did the calculation
of what it would take to merge two
hydrogen atoms
okay now what's in the nucleus of a
hydrogen atom a proton
so you have a proton here and a proton
there and i want to merge them to make a
nucleus that has two prong two two
protons in it which would be helium
that's a way to build elements from
scratch okay so
a proton is what charge
uh wait the proton is positive positive
and the charge on the other proton it's
also positive it's also positive like
charges
oh they don't really like each other
they repel okay so you have to get them
close enough
so that
the a strong nuclear force kicks in and
holds them together
okay that's the basic task
you have to
uh accomplish here sounds like
thanksgiving dinner in my crib to force
it in
get in there get in there right
so it turns out the
electromagnetic repulsion the two
positive charges
you can sort of get them closer and
closer if you speed them up
by increasing the temperature of the
plasma they'll speed up they'll get
closer and closer and closer to each
other as you increase the temperature
okay that's it so you ask at what
temperature will they be close enough
for the strong nuclear force to kick in
and grab them
okay that's the question okay that's the
question okay that temperature's like a
billion degrees well there you have it
a billion and we look when we do the
calculation for the centers of stars
it's not a billion degrees
so i'm taking it that the
building of the elements
doesn't work by getting a billion
degrees no it would if you could if you
could but i'm saying that yeah right
right so so the question was
so that i think was eddington the famous
physicist of the day astrophysicist he
was asked
he said well then where are we going to
get the elements i don't know where but
if it's gonna happen anywhere it's gonna
be in the center of stars
okay so even though we couldn't give him
a billion degrees right he still said
i don't see any place else in the
universe that will satisfy the needs of
this requirement except the centers of
stars okay so there it just sat for
decades
okay
not many decades but we just sat there
as an unsolved problem
until quantum physics came along
and then they said okay
here's a proton coming close to another
proton so there's a barrier there
that it can't cross
but wait a minute the particles are also
waves and part of that wave exists
within the graph of the grasp of the
strong nuclear force right
and so there's a probability that some
of these particles
will merge and make
helium
wow so then you say what is that
probability so
so they said well what is the
temperature the center of the star they
said 10 million degrees that's not a
billion it's like 10 15 million so
you do the math on the quantum physics
and you say what percentage of
collisions
will
will tunnel
through this barrier and end up making
helium you come up with that percent and
bada bing
you recreate the total energy output of
the sun
look at that
so you're glad it's not converting every
encounter into energy right the sun
would just blow up
it would add to smithereens well yeah
yes just like why is everything
god
damn is hot
says the alert says the person who by
then is just a puff of smell exactly
you don't have time to utter those words
right
wow
okay that all right so fast so
so so the thermonuclear fusion in stars
that generates the energy at the
temperatures it does
can only happen
because of quantum mechanical tunneling
that's
boom that is amazing and so just think
about the challenges that you know we
astrophysicists have
we have an i and by the way so eddington
was right it does happen in the centers
of stars of course right
because nowhere else was
rational right but we didn't know enough
physics at the time it was proposed to
answer that question
new physics had to be invented and this
is why we are always so excited when new
physics comes along there are people
saying people say oh someone has a new
physics idea and but the everyone else
is rejecting it because they don't want
to lose their highly invested lives in
this in this they're thinking that we
don't like new ideas they got to you
neil
we love
new ideas because they give a whole new
understanding on the frontier of stuff
that we didn't previously understand
right
and so yeah that's
quantum mechanical tunneling oh oh one
other thing
it no matter the size of that potential
barrier right
it tunnels and appears on the other side
instantly
oh so okay so okay the wave function
just collapses and it's there right it
doesn't travel there it was always there
probabilistically okay
so when your wave becomes the particle
boom it is there
so then distance makes no it's
immaterial it's important it's
immaterial it gets it's instantaneous
so we think that it moved but it really
didn't it was always there because
that is so freaky it's freaking that is
so funny all of quantum physics is
that's only part of the freaky stuff
yeah i that's like the 12th freakiest
thing i could tell you because you can't
handle the other 11. i can't handle this
[Laughter]
oh there's another one we'll save it for
another one to talk about a
bose-einstein
condensate the bose-einstein condensate
yeah let's save that for another
explainer yeah okay cool that's a good
one yeah that's a totally good one that
sounds delicious like something like
that
you know
right tonight's uh special is a
farm-raised bose-einstein condensate
um with uh an arugula compote that
we have
distilled down into a deconstructed uh
quantum
my boy's been to some restaurants late
get that fancy restaurant vocabulary
going that's pretty wild the bows
we'll get the condensate
we'll do that later in a little bit a
little bit relates to
not really but it's it's it's another
freaky wacky quantum phenomenon
that we'll say we'll say for another
time we got it
all right chuck that's another explainer
great quantum quantum tunneling baby be
there all right neil degrasse tyson here
with chuck nice
or start
[Music]